in beijing's great hall of the people
almost 3 000 communist party officials
closed china's national people's
congress
by voting on a roadmap for the next five
to 15 years
the priorities achieving six percent gdp
growth
increasing the domestic market and
creating 11 million new jobs
we would certainly be happy to see
robust growth
but we are also aware of the uncertainty
involving chinese economic rebounds
global economic development is also
uncertain
also approved by nearly all the
delegates with just one abstention
a bill to overhaul hong kong's political
system
the reforms will see seats added to the
territory's legislative council
allocated mostly to pro-beijing figures
a committee will be established to vet
those who hold public office
ensuring they're loyal to the chinese
government or considered patriots by
beijing
ted huy a former opposition politician
who fled hong kong
fearing punishment under beijing's new
national security law
has just arrived in australia and says
he's heartbroken by the reforms
it took like decades to
uh confirm and to develop uh
to finish that the design of our
constitutions
but it only took uh two or three months
to have to have that totally destroyed
and so we
we feel betrayed of course traded
and we feel miserable
of losing our freedoms the u.s is
leading growing international criticism
about the changes
saying they're an attack on hong kong's
democratic freedoms
strained ties between the two countries
were a focal point of this year's
national people's congress
washington has called beijing a
strategic threat china's leaders have
responded by pushing for a more
innovation-driven economy
china now has much more focus
on using domestic resources and
increasing domestic
investment in basic research
like biology semiconductors
so i think now the competition between
china and the u.s
will stay for a long time it makes
economic sense for china to be more
self-reliant
president xi jinping has called for an
increase to china's military capability
china's leaders say they want to work
with the biden administration to expand
common interests top officials from the
u.s and china are expected to meet in
alaska next week
to discuss a range of issues but a long
list of disagreements threatens to
overshadow the talks
including beijing's treatment of muslim
uighurs in xinjiang
china's communist party says its
approach to the uyghurs and hong kong
are strictly domestic affairs
and it won't be swayed by so-called
foreign interference
katrina you al jazeera beijing